vous débutez aux échecs et vous ne savez
pas comment réagir quand on vous met
échec au roi voici un moyen
mémotechnique hyper simple pour avoir
toujours la solution à vos problèmes on
appelle ça la méthode pif je vais dire
des trucs simples voyons ensemble un
exemple les blancs vous font échec au
roi avec le fou trois possibilité P pour
prendre si on peut capturer la pièce qui
nous embête alors c'est souvent la
meilleure solution deuxième possibilité
le i pour intercepter c'estd qu'on va
mettre une pièce en bouclier entre
l'attaquant et notre roi là on pourra
mettre le fou devant le cavalier en
obstruction même un pion la dame ce
serait une mauvaise idée puisqu'on
perdrait une pièce plus puissante après
qu'il nous la mange avec le fou mais en
tout cas ça fait partie de toutes les
possibilités et enfin le F pour fuir
c'est-à-dire déplacer notre roi sur une
case libre par exemple en E7 là ça
serait pas une bonne idée puisque le
cavalier pourrait nous donner un
terrible échec Etat en tous les cas
retenez la méthode pif P pour prendre i
intercepter F fuir sans pour autant
jouer au hasard